How much math do you want? As deep as the ocean?
Brilliant. I was trying to decide how much math
to actually include in this series but it
seems you guys just want all of the math so...
Welcome to this episode of my Ray Tracing
series, where we're going to do some mathematics!
In all seriousness though ray tracing
of course does involve a lot of math
lots of rendering and graphics programming
does in general so over the course of this
series i am going to try and include like
as much math as possible i'm not going to go
down into the extreme depths of the ocean even
though that pole really wants me to both because
i am not like a professional mathematician and
also because i feel like i will lose a lot of
people in this series if i just talk about
math all day remember at the end of the day
this series is still meant to be practical however
if you actually understand the math that goes into
what we're doing in this series not only is it
really helpful for the future it's also just
really interesting so yeah buckle in so first
of all if you haven't seen the first episode of
the series then i'll have it linked over there
highly recommend you check it out because it
explains what this series is but we're doing all
that stuff so i don't have to waste time here
explaining everything so our first goal along this
epic journey is going to be to render a sphere
like this what you're seeing on the screen right
here is going to be our step one i want to be able
to specify a camera somewhere in 3d space a sphere
somewhere in 3d space and then generate an image
which describes this scene which shows this scene
now this is in fact a sphere it looks kind of like
a circle because it's completely flat shaded we
can't actually tell that it's a sphere because
it's just a constant color but if we add a little
directional light over there somewhere and do some
very basic lighting calculations then you can
see that we can now see the form of the sphere
a little better it is in fact a sphere i told
you so so why is sphere anyway why not like a
cube or some kind of other shape the reason why we
love sphere so much is because they are extremely
simple to define mathematically all spheres are
really are just like a 3d coordinate which defines
its origin where is it in the world and then
just a radius which defines how big the sphere is
that's all you need just a three dimensional point
and a radius so where do we begin if we want to
draw this sphere well in today's episode what
we're going to do is deep dive into the math that
we'll actually need to use in order to draw this
sphere that is to send rays out from the camera
and see if they actually intersect the sphere and
we'll also talk about what array actually is like
mathematically and what a sphere is mathematically
and the best part is we're going to do all of this
math by hand like on paper that's right ray
tracing on paper however we are going to make
a small compromise instead of doing all the math
that we need to do in 3d we're actually going to
take it down a notch and do all this math here
today in 2d however there's really not as much
difference as they might seem between 2d and 3d
in this case really the only difference is that
a sphere will have a z component it will have as
like a z dimension whereas a circle which is what
we're going to be talking about here today does
not it's just got x and y the result is just a
little less math that we need to do but the math
extends into a third dimension really easily
and we'll talk about that here today as well
since obviously when it comes time to writing
our actual ray tracing code we will need to be
dealing with three dimensions now the math that
you'll already need to know in order to follow
along with this video is fairly simple it's
just like high school level math really however
if you want to revise your math or if you find
that you're not just you're not getting certain
parts of this video then i highly recommend you
take a look at brilliant the sponsors of today's
video because brilliant is my first choice for
math courses if you don't know what brilliant
is brilliant is an amazing website filled with
courses on various stem topics and i particularly
love their math courses unlike other course
websites brilliance courses are extremely engaging
and interactive they show everything visually they
quiz you on the content that they teach you and
they also give you like these amazing interactive
elements to play with that just helps you learn
this kind of visual and practical learning
is i think by far the best way to learn this kind
of stuff because if you're actually seeing it and
then putting it into practice like we will
be doing in this series as well you'll just
retain the information and learn it much faster
and it'll be way more effective brilliance math
courses cover a huge range of topics including
plenty that will be very very useful for this
series in fact i actually used brilliant myself to
revise some of the math that i would need for this
series not a joke i'm being 100 honest they've
also got a bunch of other courses on like computer
science topics data structures neural networks
that kind of stuff if you're interested in stuff
other than math the best thing about brilliant
is that you can get started for free just go to
my link in the description below brilliant.org
the churno and brilliant have been nice enough
to offer the first 200 of my subscribers
who go to that link in the description below
20 off an annual membership so yeah definitely go
check out brilliant it's honestly just a really
good way to go over some math that you'll need for
this series and for programming and for life huge
thank you brilliant for sponsoring this video all
right nothing else really for me to say here let's
let's begin the math so first and foremost
we have to understand what a line is
a line and a ray are kind of similar but they
can be interpreted differently depending on how
you look at it if we draw a basic cartesian plane
here where we have a y-axis and an x-axis one of
the simplest equations we can possibly draw is a
line like this which has the equation y equals x
what this means is that for any given x values
let's just say x is 2 over here y is equal to x
so y will also be 2 and we know that for any
point along this line the x and the y values will
be identical this thing over here is your basic
line equation now you can expand this a little bit
y equals mx plus c probably rings a bell that
simply adds a slope to the line so you can
have a line that has a different angle or even
goes down like this if it's negative and then c
is simply translating the line along that y axis
because if x is zero and this cancels out entirely
then we're left with y equals c which means that
for x equals zero c determines where our point
will be if x is zero over here what the y value
will be now if we go over here to desmos.com
which is a fantastic online graphing calculator
i can just type in y equals x and you can see
we have our line over here a straight line
running through the origin where for any
x value the y value will also be the same now
that's fantastic but does it really help us with
ray tracing and is this a good equation to use
the answer is well not really because this is an
extremely simple equation that we can use for
graphing however in the real world we want to
use vectors and in fact we want to use vectors
that have an arbitrary amount of components
usually two or three what this means is that
rather than expressing our equation like this
we want to be able to specify just a point
somewhere in 2d or 3d space that is the origin
of our line so where does our line actually begin
and then we want to be able to specify a direction
for that line to go in and this kind of setup
here is what you would call array and that's
how a ray differs from a line now to be honest
i don't feel 100 comfortable saying that because
everyone's definition of all of these terms might
actually be different but traditionally array is
something that contains an origin and a direction
usually expressed in terms of vectors now as i
mentioned in the first part of this video we are
going to be thinking of everything in 2d today
however just because we are going to be talking
about this stuff in 2d meaning we'll have x and
y components and no z component you just add a
z component and it becomes 3d right i want to
make that clear that all of this stuff translates
extremely easily into 3d it's just that it's much
simpler to kind of draw and show this stuff and
do the actual manual working out if we have one
less component one less dimension so since we are
in 2d origin will have an x and a y component and
direction will also have an x and a y component
so these are just like vectors basically we have
two component vectors here where one of them is
a point in 2d space so a point somewhere in our
world which is the origin and then we have a
direction which is where this actually points
now in order to actually define this line though
we need to be able to sample a point along the
line somewhere and this is where our magical t
parameter comes in which is really the distance
of the point along the line it's sometimes also
called a scalar because it will scale the origin
along the directional vector however if you're new
a good way to think of it is just the distance so
what that means now is that we have an origin
now i'm going to give these slightly different
names i'm just going to call the origin a and the
direction b why well mostly because the origin
looks like a zero and it can get confusing but
also because a and b are really simple variables
too to think of so if we have our origin over here
we can express this ray equation as a plus b and
then that scale of value t now these two of course
are being multiplied together and since these are
vectors in two-dimensional space a has an x and a
y component and b has an x and a y component and
to finish off this equation we could say that a
point along this line is equal to the origin plus
the direction along with the distance along that
line and just to kind of test this out and show
you what i'm talking about if the origin x y was
like somewhere here maybe let's just say it's at 2
2. and we had a direction for the line which was
in the direction of 1 1 so it's kind of going in
the positive axis both x and y then if we wanted
to find a point that was like well i don't know
two meters or two units down that line we would
simply set t equal to two and so if we plug it in
with the rest of this equation we know that point
x y will be equal to the origin which is 2 2 plus
the direction which is 1 1 times t which is 2. now
i know that these are in vector form which might
make it look like it's a bit trickier to solve
however we can actually separate these by axis
does not matter here at all since x and y are
actually identical they're both two and they're
both one here so we can just kind of ignore one
of them however basically if we just do this math
we have two plus one times two which is just two
plus two which is four and so we know the result
here is four four which means that if you move
along this line by two units you will end up at
four four which as you expect is the correct
answer so that's how we can kind of use this
equation now if you're paying close attention you
probably notice that we moved more than two units
along that line we actually moved around 2.8
because we moved 2 units in the x and 2 units
in the y to get 4 4. the reason this happened
is because our directional vector for our ray b
is not a unit vector you can see it's 1 1. we
would have to normalize that and bring it down
to like 0.7 x and 0.7y roughly then it would be a
unit vector and then we would in fact have moved
2 units along that line if we pass in 2 for t
however it doesn't really matter for this example
or for the rest of this video so we'll just ignore
that 1 1 is just a lot easier to deal with now if
t is negative then we will go backwards from
the origin and that's totally valid as well so
because this line equation in vector form can be
a little bit awkward to solve if the values aren't
identical in x and y we can actually split this
up by dimension or by component so in other words
p x will actually be a x plus b x t and then
p y so the y coordinate will be a y plus b y
t right so it's totally okay to just kind of
split these two up and these are often called
the parametric equations and of course as you
can imagine if we did have another axis like z
we would simply have another one of these where we
would have the origin z component and direction z
component here as well now the reason these are
called parametric equations is because we have
a parameter in the line which is actually t the
distance along the line that should be fairly
familiar to you if you're a programmer which i
assume most of you watching this series probably
are parameter variable same kind of thing okay
so these two equations here are going to be quite
important so we're going to just remember them now
since we are in 2d we're going to be focusing on
circles and not spheres now spheres and circles
are remarkably similar the only difference is that
spheres of course have a z axis a z dimension and
circles do not so we've talked about the equation
of a line and all of the various different forms
that we might need to know so let's talk about
what it takes to actually draw a circle well the
equation of a circle is x minus a squared plus
y minus b squared equals r squared so what on
earth does this mean well x and y are basically
just our coordinates along this plane somewhere
so you can kind of ignore those the same way that
we would ignore y and x over here since that's
what we're actually showing a and b however are
basically the coordinates of the circle's origin
and r is the radius so if we look at a circle like
this one here we can see that the origin is 0
0 over here because it's centered at the origin
and then we have some kind of radius that defines
a circle so it could be something like 1 or 2. and
of course if it is 2 then we would have a point
over here which is 0 2 and a point here which is 2
0 because we know that the radius is going to be
2 units now if we are going to be dealing with a
circle that is in fact centered at the origin
over here that means that a and b are just 0
0 which means that if we plug in 0 into a and b
over here you'll see that we of course get x minus
0 y minus 0 which is just the same as x squared
plus y squared equals radius squared so this will
just simplify the equation here now let's give our
circle a radius so sure let's go with two so what
that means is that our equation now looks like x
squared plus y squared equals two squared which is
four now the next step's going to be to take this
and graph it to make it a little bit easier for
ourselves though let's rearrange this so that it
actually looks like it's in the same form as this
equation over here so i want it to be y equals
something so to do that let's go ahead and move x
square to the other side of the equation so we'll
have y squared equals 4 minus x squared and then
to get just y we'll have to square root both sides
so we'll have y equals the square root of 4 minus
x squared pretty simple pretty basic algebra
so now that we have the equation in this form
let's go ahead and go to our graphing calculator
and we'll type that in y equals square root 4
minus x squared all right check this out we get
something however it looks like we've just got
half a circle a semicircle in the positive y
axis why is that now i'm not going to get too
deep into this but what i will say is that the
problem with square roots as you may already know
is that there are essentially multiple solutions
two solutions commonly to a square root
why well the square root of four is two because
2 squared is 4. however -2 squared is also 4
because -2 times -2 is a positive value 4. so
therefore how do we know if the square root of 4
is positive two or negative two and the answer
is we do not know it could be either one there
are literally multiple solutions two solutions
to this problem over here and so because there
are multiple solutions to this if we want to
actually see our entire circle on the graph we
need to basically have a plus and a minus on the
result of the square root because we know that if
we have a real value there meaning a value inside
the square root that actually amounts to being
above zero because we can't have the square root
of a negative number that's an imaginary number
and we're only sticking to real numbers here today
we can just show the positive and the negative
solution so if we copy our equation here and
basically paste it into here but flip this to be
a negative then you can now see that we have our
complete circle because we're taking into account
both of these solutions okay wonderful so we've
basically graphed this problem here that we're
going to be spending the rest of today solving and
that is if i do in fact have a ray that originates
well let's just say it like minus three minus
three over here and if that ray goes in this kind
of direction of positive one x and positive
one y how do i know if it actually collides
with this circle and where it collides along this
circle so we can actually see visually what the
solutions are they're around minus 1.41 just just
the square root of two and positive 1.41 however
seeing it visually like this is all great but if
we're going to be writing a computer program to
do this for us then we're going to have to set
this up in terms of equations not just visually
kind of winging it even though yes in mathematics
of course this is a valid way to solve equations
but the cool thing about seeing it visually like
this is we know we have a way to basically double
check our working out and make sure our solution
is correct because we can visually see these two
points of intersection here so going back to
here how can we actually solve this equation
and in fact in case we're getting a little bit
lost let's talk about how this relates back to
ray tracing so first of all we discussed what the
equation of a circle is it's basically this thing
here right now can you guess what the equation
of a sphere is well you'd be very correct if you
guessed that it's exactly the same thing however
with that z component so we basically also have
a z minus c which is that third component of the
sphere's origin and then if we wanted to move this
radius and onto this side we could just do that
and then have it equal zero like that so this
is the equation of a sphere extremely similar to
the equation of a circle the only difference is of
course we just don't have this area over here if
we are dealing with a circle and so we end up with
just this and that is our circle so when we're
actually trying to render a sphere in our ray
tracer the math that we're actually doing is
very similar to what i've shown you here in 2d
we basically have this image of a sphere which i
showed in the beginning of the video that's kind
of what we're aiming to achieve and we can see
if we play around with some lighting that it is
in fact a 3d sphere even though if it's flatly lit
it kind of looks like a circle but no it does in
fact have volume because the math that we're doing
for it is three-dimensional and so if we look at
how we synthesize this image from the side right
what we're kind of doing is we're shooting out all
these different rays which accounts one per pixel
and so over here in our side view if we have our
camera we have our sphere over here this thing
here is our camera then what we're actually doing
is shooting out all these different lines here
and then seeing where they intersect the sphere
and wherever they actually do intersect the sphere
we're setting that pixel whatever coordinate that
pixel lies at we're setting that pixel's color to
be a particular value now this could be calculated
if we're doing lighting it could be a flat color
if we're just doing a flat color but the point is
we're able to know that the line here actually
hits this sphere and then we can do something
with that result either figure out where it hit
the sphere and then do some extra calculations
such as figuring out what the normal is of that
particular point in 3d space or even just a simple
binary yes no did we hit it is enough to just
shade it a flat color if however our array
misses the sphere and there is no collision then
we can just return whatever the background color
is basically or in a more complex scene maybe we
have other objects to test for but for now we just
have a single sphere so if we forget about the
third dimension here and we go back to what this
looks like you can imagine that our camera might
be somewhere at minus three minus three and then
this ray this line here that represents a ray that
is just one of the rays that we're sending out for
one of the pixels that we're trying to determine
the color of that's going to be rendered in our
viewport and this circle of course is that sphere
but in 2d space so our job at the moment is
having the equation of the circle well defined
and having the equation of the line the ray
well defined i want to work out using the power
of math if this ray intersects this circle and
where exactly it intersects the circle and again
the beauty of this is that if i can do it like
this in two dimensions then i can easily do
it in three dimensions the only difference
is going to be that extra z-axis and that is
it so let's go ahead and solve it so the first
thing that i actually want to do is kind of just
define what our actual line and circle look like
so we know that the line if our equation here
for that is going to be a plus bt we know that a
is going to be minus 3 minus 3 because that's
where we've decided that line is starting minus 3
minus 3 this point over here and then it's heading
in a direction of 1 1 which is just going to
basically have it go one unit positive x-axis for
every one unit that it climbs up in the positive
y-axis as well we don't really have to worry too
much about this being a unit vector by the way
so this is our kind of complete line now for our
circle equation which we know is x squared plus
y squared minus r squared equals zero if it
is centered on the origin there is no a and
b component which in fact the circle's origin
is zero zero so there is no a and b component
and the radius squared we've decided is 2.
so this circle over here has a radius of
2 as we can see so that means that really r is
just equal to 2 which squared is 4 but we'll just
write it as 2 like this so this is actually enough
information to work out where the hit takes place
so how do we actually do this well we're simply
going to just solve this equation and we're going
to do so by using the powers of substitution to
begin with so the first thing we're going to do
is a of course has two components x and y b
also has two components x and y so what we're
actually going to do is write this per axis per
dimension so in other words this equation kind
of splits up into two where we have ax plus bx
t and then also a y plus b y t right these are
kind of our two equations what we're going to
do is we're going to plug this one into the x
and this one into the y of this equation here so
what that means is that this equation becomes a x
plus b x t squared plus a y plus b y t squared
minus r squared which is just two squared which
is 4 so i'll just write minus 4 equals 0. now at
first glance this might look completely useless
but let's just continue simplifying this we're
actually going to expand these brackets and see
what we can come up with so if you remember how to
expand brackets it's a bit of a pain and also this
is one of the reasons why i decided to go with
circles not sphere so we'd have less brackets to
expand but basically ax plus bx t squared right is
the same thing as just this so we have two copies
of this and to expand these brackets remember you
have to basically multiply each component here
with each component here until you've gone through
like all of the combinations now the beauty of
this though is that if we expand this one bracket
here we know that it's going to be the same
for this second bracket here except instead of x
we're gonna have y so we only need to do this once
which is a good thing so ax times ax gives us ax
squared man i feel like a high school math teacher
at this point then the next one over here is going
to be ax times bxt which is going to give us ax
bx t then we have bx t times ax which is actually
the same thing so i'm just going to sneak a 2 in
here because we have two of these and then we have
b x t times b x t which gives us b x t squared now
this whole thing is actually squared because we
have the multiplication of two components here
and actually since we were all about simplifying
this by removing the brackets we might as well
write this as bx squared t squared so that is that
bracket expanded so if i also do the same thing
here and i just copy this but replace the x's with
the y's because we know it'll be the same we have
a y squared plus 2 a y b y t plus b y squared
t squared that's all of it and then minus four
equals zero now that is a monster of an equation
here however we notice a trend here now remember
what we're actually trying to solve we have the
equation of the line we have the equation of a
circle that's all well defined what we're actually
trying to solve for here is t right because we
want to know if there is a a hit along that ray if
there's a collision along that line and where that
collision is so the cool thing about this is that
we notice that this actually can be rearranged to
be a quadratic equation now a quadratic equation
if you remember is like ax squared plus bx plus
c equals zero so the point here is that we have
an x squared we have an x that is not squared and
we can optionally have like some kind of constant
value here and that is exactly what we're seeing
over here but with t right we have t squared
in two places we have t by itself in two places
right and then we have just some other terms
like ax squared and minus four that is just
like our constant term so let's go ahead and
kind of rearrange this so that we express it in
terms of t so what that means is that we're going
to group all the terms that are t squared which
is just this one here and then this one here so
this is simply going to be b x squared plus b y
squared and then all of that's going to be
multiplied by t squared so there's our t squared
component then we're going to add in just the t
terms so this one over here and this one over here
are our two t terms so 2 a x b x plus 2 a y b y
t and then plus our constant terms which i want
to put in brackets here so a x squared a y squared
and so this one here this one here this one here
i'm just double checking that i've got everything
and it looks like i do so a x squared plus
a y squared and then the minus four which i'll
also put over here equals zero okay so now you
can see quite clearly hopefully that we have a
quadratic equation now i've deliberately put it
into this first before subbing in the actual
values because remember we know these values
the only value we don't know is t b x and b y
are just the directional values the directional
vector of our actual ray ax and ay are just the
origin of the ray so we actually know everything
except for t but having the equation written out
like this as a quadratic equation is great because
now we can just move the line around if we want
to and we've already got it in the right form so
really all we need to do is just plug in different
values and in fact -4 dictates the radius
of the circle so if we want to make the circle
smaller smaller or larger we can actually do that
the only thing we can't really do is move it away
from the origin without kind of redoing this thing
but using the non-simplified equation right
so i simplified it so that it was just
uh you know not x minus a and y minus b but just
x squared plus y squared we'd have to sub in
like this actual thing so that we have a and b for
our circle and then we could move it around if we
wanted to but i've just simplified this because as
you can see the manual working out can be a little
bit tedious anyway so next step then is going to
be to sub all of this stuff in so again a and b
are the two things we need to sub in or or a x and
b x right which we know if we go back to here that
a x is minus three a y is minus three b x is one
and b y is one so let's go ahead and sub all of
that stuff in so remember a is minus 3 minus
3 and b is 1 1. so let's begin so b x squared
so that's going to be 1 squared plus 1 squared
for y t squared plus 2 times ax which is minus 3
bx which is 1 plus 2 a y which is minus 3 b
y which is 1 all of that multiplied with t
plus ax squared which is minus three squared plus
a y which is minus three squared minus four equals
zero okay now we simplify so one squared is just
one one plus one is two so this becomes two t
squared plus all this stuff so two times minus
three is minus six times one is just minus six
plus the same thing so minus six minus six which
is minus twelve so let's just simplify that right
now we might as well minus 12 t plus whatever
this is so minus 3 squared is 9 plus 9 again
minus 4. so 18 minus 4 which is 14 positive
14 equals 0. look at that baby much smaller
and just a normal quadratic equation so what
do we do from here well we just need to solve
this quadratic equation now programmatically
the easiest way to do this is probably to use
the quadratic formula the quadratic formula is
a formula that we can derive by completing the
square which is another way to solve quadratic
equations that just gives us a really great
kind of easy equation that we can just sub in
all of our different coefficients here and see
first of all are there any solutions and what
they actually are if there are solutions so
the quadratic formula is minus b plus minus the
square root of b squared minus 4ac divided by
2a that is something called the quadratic formula
and we're about to use this so what is b what is
a and what is c well they are the coefficients to
our quadratic equation here i'm just going to move
this over here so a is going to be 2 b is going to
be -12 and c is going to be 14. and so now you can
see we can just plug in these values before we do
that though i want to focus on one specific part
of the quadratic formula which is this part inside
the square root this is called the discriminant
now the cool thing about the discriminant is that
if we plug in the values here right so a b and c
if we plug them into this part over here the value
that we get when we solve that particular part of
the equation will actually tell us if there are
any solutions and how many there are so let's go
ahead and do that first so b squared is going to
be minus 12 squared minus 4ac so 4 times a which
is 2 times c which is 14. so that's our kind of
discriminant part so let's go ahead and simplify
that so minus 12 squared is 144 minus 2 times
14 which is 28 times 4 which i think is 112.
let me just double check that yep 112. okay so
144 minus 112 is 32. so 32 is the result of this
kind of discriminant equation what does it mean
well if we get a value that is greater than zero
that means that we have two solutions if we get a
value that is equal to zero we have one solution
and if we get a value that is less than zero so
it's negative we have zero solutions that's how
this discriminant works and remember the reason
that it works that way is because if we have a
positive value inside the square root then we
know that it will be plus minus because there
are two solutions to that square root as we talked
about earlier if we have the square root of zero
however then the square root of zero is just zero
that's one solution plus minus zero it's just zero
and finally if we have a negative value inside the
square root like the square root of negative one
then there are no real solutions to that and
that's why we don't have any solutions for
that case so it all comes down to the magic
of the square root so we can actually do
just this very simple equation without
having to square root or anything else
to work out do we have any solutions now what on
earth are solutions what does that mean and why
do we care well solutions are intersections so you
can see clearly that we should expect to get two
solutions here because there are two intersections
we have this kind of entry wound and exit wound
over here as our line pierces our circle now if
the line was somewhere else so if for example
we i don't know how did it like plus four or
something we would expect that there would be
no solutions because it doesn't hit at all and if
it was like extremely close and grazing it like
that or something but even closer we'd have one
solution because it would be like a tangent to
that circle so that's pretty cool because now you
can see we can actually see whether or not our ray
hits our sphere or our circle now the cool thing
is this is actually enough to just simply draw a
circle right because if we have more than zero
solutions then we know that the ray has hit the
circle and we can just return a color whatever
color we want our circle to be and that is the
color that we should shade that particular pixel
that we've cast out that ray too that's all we
have to do if we get zero solutions well maybe
the ray is somewhere here and we're not part of
the circle at all so in other words we don't even
have to keep doing the quadratic formula but keep
solving the quadratic formula here to work out
the actual solutions to this equation we just
need to know are there solutions and if there
are solutions that's enough to draw a circle or
i should say a sphere in our 3d ray tracing case
however for more detailed scenarios we do actually
want to know where we hit this circle or sphere
so for that we're actually going to have to keep
going with this quadratic formula so we've worked
out this discriminant part we know that it's 32
so let's go ahead and sub that in so we have
minus b plus minus square root of 32 divided by
2a so let's sub in a and b over here and so we'll
get minus minus 12 plus minus square root of 32
divided by 2 times 2 right which is of course
just 12 plus minus square root of 32 divided by
4. now the square root of 32 is roughly equal to
5.66 so that's the value we'll kind of use here so
this will be 12 plus minus 5.66 divided by 4. now
again we have this plus minus here because we know
there are in fact going to be two solutions and
so if we work out both the solutions 12 plus 5.66
17.6 divided by 4 is going to give us 4.415 and
then the minus solution is going to give us 1.585
so these are our two solutions now you might be
wondering like well okay there are two solutions
we know there are two intersections but that
doesn't seem right and like what do i do with
this information like because these coordinates
clearly are very different like what's going on
well remember what we were solving for we were
solving for t so this is the value of t which is
that scalar that distance along that ray right so
what this actually tells us is how far along the
ray the intersections took place so we know that
we have one about 1.5 into the ray and we have
one at 4.4 into the ray right so these are going
to be our two intersection points now since we
obviously have a well-defined line equation we can
just simply plug in these values of t especially
because it's a parametric equation in terms
of that t parameter we can just plug in these
values here and we will get actual two dimensional
points y two dimensional points because we have
two equations here one for x and one for y so what
are the equations well first of all let's go ahead
and copy this and we will plop it right over here
so ax we know is -3 well actually they're going
to be the same right so ax and ay are the same
so we can just really do this once in this case
but minus 3 plus 1 times t which is going to be
either 1.58 for one of the intersection points
and this is going to be the same for both x and
y since they are identical and then minus 3 plus
1 times 4.415 for that other point so really it's
just going to be minus 3 plus 1.585 and minus 3
plus 4.415 so if we actually do the math here then
we're going to get negative 1.415 for this result
here and positive 1.415 for this result here now
remember because the x and y here were identical
i just haven't done this twice but it would be the
same right we'll just do it twice for the x and
for the y then what we're actually left with is
an identical x and y coordinate 1.415 so we know
that the answer of the two intersection points
are we have one intersection at this coordinate
and this was the first intersection because the
distance along the line is lower than the other
one so this is the closest hit and then the second
one over here has this coordinate here right so
positive and negative 1.415 let's go ahead and
double check with our graphing calculator and
you can see the answer is the same now of course
square root of 32 i approximated it therefore we
didn't get the exact right answer but you can
see that it is the same right negative 1.414
and positive 1.414 so we have now solved this
using all of this algebra and quadratic equation
solving math over here and the beauty is it is
exactly the same for a sphere it's just that
you have that z component as i keep saying but in
terms of how you can work out intersection points
and all that stuff it is exactly the same thing
so yeah congratulations all you have to do now
is convert this into c plus plus code and add that
third dimension as i mentioned all right that is
that is enough math for one day so the next step
is to try and take like what we've learned here
today and actually convert it into code see if you
can use this stuff to draw like an actual circle
or a sphere or at the very least just visualize
something if you can kind of convert this into
code just play around with it tinker with it
try and draw some stuff on the screen that'll
be tremendously helpful to understanding how it
works and then just go ahead and try and adapt
it into three dimensions yourself and see if you
can make it work if you do that yourself without
looking at like ray tracing in one weekend or any
other kind of resources trust me like you'll just
learn it so much better let that be like a little
homework challenge exercise for you guys while
you wait for the next episode in which we are
going to be taking what we learned here today
and drawing an actual sphere if you enjoyed this
video please don't forget to hit the like button
you can also leave your thoughts in the comments
section below don't forget to check out brilliant
using my link in the description below and i
will see you guys in the next episode goodbye
you